capable à chez toi non monsieur
bon alors je me demande ce qui va me
prendre le plus de tort de taper un coup
de pelle et traîner ton corps dans les
bois pour l'enterrer ou d'écouter ce
très bref 3 me tout d'abord laissez-moi
vous dire quel plaisir j'ai à vous
parler parce qu'ils rêvent ok alors en
fait en bref je suis fou amoureux d'une
des plus jolies filles de la région
je la suite classe en classe depuis
qu'on est gamins elle est intouchable
tous les mecs qui l'approchent
eh ben les jette comme des comme des
comme des malpropres et moi moi je suis
invisible à ses yeux n'existe même pas
j'ai besoin je sais pas moi d'une
tactique d'un conseil quelque chose en
plus c'est pas la voir quelle fille
celle là tu as une bonne je ne supporte
pas désolé quand je suis nerveuse j'ai
effectivement les cordes vocales bayonne
tendance en fait tu pas que tableau qui
me crispait adapte est aussi maintenant
une envie j'ai effectivement un peu les
traits du visage comme la gueule pagnol
ta gueule ok je qu'on se comprenne tous
les deux je veut bien t'aider mais après
tu disparais ma vie elle connoté